you are about to learn what it's like
having the coronavirus and living in
quarantine our next guest Mark Jorgenson
and his wife were on the diamond
Princess cruise ship in Japan where
their vacation turned as we all know
into a nightmare because we covered it
the ship was quarantined for two weeks
days of it
a total of 705 people ended up testing
positive for kovat 19 out of the nearly
4,000 people on board his wife was kept
in Japan until she tested negative while
mark was allowed to fly back to the
United States and quarantined in Utah
and was eventually sent home even though
his tests still now show positive mark
Jorgensen joins me now mark first of all
how are you feeling I feel just fine how
was your wife she's doing okay - she's
quarantine and she's doing very well and
she was sick enough for them at one
point I should tell our viewers for her
to be taken off the diamond princess and
put in the hospital in Japan tell me how
this started and and you can start with
just when you started to see symptoms
well we really didn't see symptoms until
we were tested we were tested because
they considered me high-risk like I'm a
kidney transplant patient and so they
bring the quarantine they came to our
room and tested us and then the next
night my wife started to have a little
bit of a high fever and didn't feel
really well but by the next morning that
was gone but they came in and told us
she was positive and took her to the
hospital where she spent two weeks and
mostly felt fine while she was there
were you able to get off the ship as
well and go see your wife in Japan I did
not see her in Japan two days after they
took her is when they took that big
group on those planes and I vacua to
that group and we went to Travis Air
Force Base and I met her I tested
positive how was it your decision to get
off the ship and go home was it hard to
leave her behind it kind of was yeah we
talked about it she and I talked about
it because but then we realized even if
I'd stayed in Japan I
wouldn't be able to be with or we'd
still be communicating by phone or Skype
or whatever and so we decided was best
like police got back in the state where
where I could you know take care of
myself take care of everything else
and you're still in quarantine at this
point because you're still testing
positive right I am still testing
positive I tested positive at Travis and
then I went to a couple hospitals in
California they transferred me to Salt
Lake was in a hospital there for about a
week and then they were able to work out
where I could do a home quarantine and
that's where I've been for the past
eight nine days and they come twice a
week and test me dan I've got actually
got a test scheduled for this afternoon
and still positive so far now when you
say you were in the hospital did you
eventually show symptoms too and how
sick were you I didn't I never showed
any symptoms at all I test pod tested
positive you know continuously through
the whole process
why don't they hospitalized because I
was well they wanted to quarantine me
that was you know in the early days but
anyone who had it was immediately taken
away from others and quarantine to keep
from spreading and that's where I was I
know that you and your wife cannot be
near each other so we should tell our
viewers that you are social distancing
inside your home which is why we don't
see her standing right next to you I
wish you wrecked the best mark I hope
that you get a negative today and you're
testing for coronavirus god bless you
and thank you for your time and sharing
your story thanks for having yours
absolutely glad they're home the first
clinical trial for a potential
coronavirus vaccine reportedly is
getting underway today however the
Surgeon General warns it will be an
instant fix as the number of cases here
and around the globe continues to climb
we'll break it all down next and bring
back the doctors of course